[Music]
you're joris i'll never eat it right
again
i'll never eat right again this podcast
will get locked
[Music]
you man your people turns out
you don't care of us
it turns out you actually don't oh you
just you don't care you don't
care last week's episode um
yeah yeah yeah yeah we pulled our hearts
out
and
and i was like it's gonna pop it
actually didn't turns out you're paying
props to you man that did yeah we're not
dismissing you
we're not dismissing you at all but
those that didn't heartless
pagans literally literally you said you
you heard him saying he was like yeah i
am picking
you say something to me i don't care
right respect yourself man it's all good
um to yourself that's what it is that's
all we can do man we can now be true to
ourselves so
we're ever in it um if you don't care
about us we don't care about you
you're missing out um so that's fine
it's all good
um and that reminds me actually
actually while we're on the topic guys
no no no off patrons okay so while we're
on the top of the patrons yeah yeah
patrons who pay tier three
yeah so sorry so sorry
you guys are entitled to a shout
personal shout out on the show
and we've never done it not once i
always forget about that
it's it's guys just it's not something
that i just put in there and never
intended to do yeah it's at the top of
my phone list
every single time i look at my notes for
this podcast it's right there
shout out patrons yeah it literally says
it in capitals
i i it didn't start in capitals it was
normal
now it's capitals bold and underlying
still don't do it so guys i'm so sorry
i'm gonna pull up the thing now
um and you're gonna get your love we're
gonna shine some love on each and every
one of you right
right now gang gang gang gang
so if you guys want to get shouted well
you know what to do hey this is going to
be a regular thing
yeah sign up to the party man sign up to
the crew right so let me give you some
love guys let me give you some love this
is
long overdue way overdue so i'm so sorry
right and i will pronounce your names
incorrectly
just know that that's going to happen
and just just embrace it this is not a
personal attack
i will pronounce your [ __ ] incorrect
your [ __ ]
but that's fine just know it's for you
in it so um
first one this is a newbie i saw this
one coming the other day
um benissa vanessa whatever
yeah um don't worry not whatever but
yeah benissa yeah
yeah we got a lovely message did you
read it i read the message lovely
messages
lovely message yeah we don't forget
stuff like that thank you so much
we appreciate you we love you gang
sounds like madam are doing doughnuts
out there couple men are doing donuts
outside and they're trying to ruin the
they're trying to [ __ ] with the
production but it's not gonna happen
not what i'm sharing love with the
patrons the ride or die is no no not
today
not today not today not today um so yeah
benissa we love you thank you
uh welcome to the crew uh newest member
of the rideal dies
um this one is a weird one
because it's like named under two people
uh
like ashley and sean oh i never know if
we're talking to ashley and sean
sean or ashley yeah yeah so ashley and
sean it's the couple with this this is
the racial couple yeah yeah yeah you see
this you know we've seen it though yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah um i actually think
they've recently dropped off
obviously um this is a hard economy you
know i know that it's not
personal to us i know it's not personal
to us but thank you for the time that
you spent with us thank you very much
you sent us some
uh lovely messages um some decent
contributions
so ashley and sean ashley all sean thank
you so much
um love from you uh my main man aidan
he's been with us for a couple months
now yes yes two three months now i think
yeah
um aiden we fox with you hard thank you
very much
um you can pronounce this next one gee
um oh
i don't even know if that's if it is a
first and surname i forgive me i think
it's
iok akol that's an i at the end no
that's not an l that's an i are you sure
no i'm not sure
that's an l oh is it l is it l is it oh
my bad
i've seen that name a couple times yeah
i have i've seen it busy busy busy
busy yeah busy man like ethan
ethan's a guy he's been with us for a
minute new zealand i think
i'm not too sure i can't i can't record
a place but i want to say new zealand
for ethan
um he's a blessed guy i like ethan a lot
he's cool
uh yeah he pops up a lot makes some
decent contributions um
yeah i like this guy he's cool uh guys
obviously you know we're supposed to be
doing our chat with you this is a good
time to announce the monthly chat yes um
so obviously we attempted the youtube
live a couple months ago it flopped
audio didn't even work
um which no one's decided to tell us
which is probably they probably thought
our [ __ ]
they're they're it's [ __ ] up on their
side yeah until who was it was it callum
i can't remember who it was it was
towards the end of it yeah towards the
end of the whole thing
someone popped up and was like just so
you know guys i don't know if it's my
fault but i can't hear you
and i was like damn no one could hear us
the whole time but anyway guys
we've just uh we're gonna move the month
the month chat over to stereo the app
stereo
so this is going to be us we'll send you
over private links as on when we're
going to do it
um so we have no rude interruptions yeah
it's just going to be
uh once a month with you guys and you
guys can contribute via voice notes
and we'll discuss the topics chat with
you guys and it's going gonna be fun so
that's gonna be coming once a month for
you guys very shortly
these men are doing doughnuts outside
our gaff
and it's jarring uh you probably won't
be able to hear it on this
but we it's just like it's in the yard
yeah
um as if to say they know whether they
know they know what we're trying to do
and they don't [ __ ] with it at all um
and then lastly callum my main guy been
with us for a minute as well
um love the contributions appreciate you
bro and uh yeah
thank you mom that's everyone for now
thank you guys um it has been a minute
since we've actually
decided to do that and say the name so
so i'm so sorry
i i take all the blame don't don't blame
through for this one this is all me like
i said it's been in my notes
i always literally say like cool need to
shout out the patrons yeah and then
i just we just you literally start your
fun fact yeah and um
you forget you're my i'll just go so
it's yeah my bad guys but
got it now guys your names are out there
we love you thank you
um and guys obviously jump on the
patreon stop [ __ ] around
there's two episodes a month on there um
the
the the picky poison topic is is booming
i know you guys have been feeling the
clips on the youtube that'll be coming
out every thursday as well so um
yeah man jump in enjoy send us your
contributions as always and uh
that's enough of an introduction for
today thank you guys don't forget to
like comment subscribe leave us a review
if you're listening on the
any audio platform and yeah man let's
get with it
so the fun fact is today it's a juicy
one there's a guy called
frayne select he's a croatian man he's
dubbed as the world's
unluckiest luckiest man
okay i saw this on tick tock and i had
to find out more
yeah yeah it was brief so i just had to
find out yeah yeah yeah
so i'm just going to read the whole
thing he has his own wikipedia page okay
he has he's had so many brushes with
death
it's it's crazy you you think it's fake
so i'm just gonna read it out for you
so frank salek born in 1929
is a croatian man who is known for his
luck and is often addressed as the
world's most
unlucky luckiest man okay
salek's near-death experience began in
january 1962
when he was riding a train through a
cold rainy canyon and
the train flew off the tracks and
crashed into a river an
unknown person pulled select to safety
while 17 other passengers
drowned and died salix suffered from a
broken arm
and hypothermia the next year during his
first and only plane ride he was blown
out of a
malfunctioning plane door and landed in
a haystack
that's impossible hold on fam hold on
hold on now you'll get my blood going
that's impossible
this is brush number two with death the
plane crashed killed 19 people three
years after in 1966
a bus that he was riding a bus that he
was riding in so he skidded off the road
and into a river drowning four
passengers sonic swam to shore with a
few cuts and bruises
in 1970 his car caught on fire
and he was driving as his car caught on
fire as he was driving sorry
and he managed to escape before the fuel
tank blew up three years later in
another driving incident
the engine of his car was doused with
hot oil from a malfunctioning fuel pump
causing flames to shoot through the air
vents salix hair was completely
singed in this incident but he was
otherwise unharmed
in 1995 he was struck by a bus
in zagreb but sustained only minor
injuries
in 1996 he eluded a head-on collision
with a united nations truck on a
mountain curve by swerving into a guard
rail
which gave way under the force two days
after his 73rd birthday
salek won 900 000 euros in the lottery
he he won a lottery as well he won 900
000 euros in the lottery at this time he
was
at this time of his win he also married
for the fifth time
while he purchased two houses and a boat
with his winnings in 2010
being generous he decided to give most
of his remaining money
away to relatives friends and after
deciding to live a frugal lifestyle
so that was probably the longest fun
facts but he yeah he's defied
death so much so
[ __ ] much that's ridiculous bro
so for starters that sounds like the
plot of unbreakable
the um uh m night shyamalan movie the um
so it's unbreakable
glass okay okay and uh unbreakable is
the
first one i don't think i've ever seen
it you know i've seen glass is the third
one
that's the last one and then what's it
called split split i've seen split i've
never seen unbreakable
movie what's his name
jackson samuel jackson and what's his
name bro faces in my head the guy that
does die hard yeah the most famous guy
bruce willis bruce willis yeah um yeah
yeah basically
um unbreakable's a [ __ ] movie really
[ __ ] movie bro i don't know because i
saw it i'm not shaman's best mover
anyway actually is because he's a trash
director as far as i've heard
he's a trans director trash director how
he keeps getting jobs i don't know
because he did
the real life version of it yeah i could
have murdered him for that
it was so dead he could have murdered it
for it
they called him aung they're called on
how'd you get that wrong that's the most
basic [ __ ]
man didn't even watch the show he just
decided i'm gonna do a live action of it
bro vex i've never been that's the
biggest disappointment
movie i've ever had in my life i've seen
it once and once early i've not seen it
again shocking movie i'm never going to
watch that again
shocking movie [ __ ] you i'm not
shyamalan bro [ __ ] you
every time i think about that i get so
vexed but unbreakable
pops unbreakable pops i watch it tonight
um
yeah he's a narcissist as well he always
puts himself in his own movies
um yeah yeah he's in he's in yeah he's
he's in all of them oh i'm pretty sure
he's like a quintessential kind of yeah
but you ain't quit and you get me
true no one yeah he clinton's got that
clown he can do what we want no one is
quitting tarantino
but anyway um yeah unbreakable uh it's
literally that
it's like um so you know how obviously
in glass
uh this is i've only seen split i've not
seen glass
so you don't even know the plot no
because obviously i i never knew
there was a first one up until i watched
split oh only after i watched split that
and i had realized it was the
end cut away scene at the end of split i
can't remember i've seen it i've only
split once it was years ago
oh okay i don't remember it oh i know
it's about i know the premise of split
so yeah
obviously a split there's there's no
point in split that it says it's in the
same universe as unbreakable
because unbreakable came out [ __ ]
years ago
like that yeah oh no it came out years
ago it came out years ago it came out
years ago i said 82
came out time ago yeah but
uh yeah so there's no there's no
indication in that movie
in split that has anything to do with um
unbreakable
okay until the very end okay
where um where they show bruce willis
they're show bruce willis sitting in the
in the diner dining yeah cafe wherever
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so that's
the only time you know there's actually
anything to do with it okay
so basically the premise is i'll try my
best products you should still watch
them yeah i'm definitely going to watch
it
yeah yeah yeah so basically the whole
premises is samuel jackson
is born with uh obviously like he calls
himself mr glass
because he's he breaks his bones easily
okay he's got like a disease that just
he
he was born with like a hundred broken
bones like he breaks his bones like that
so he spent all his life just reading
comic books okay
and this sorry is this the premise of
the first one or the last one first one
okay
so he he grows up reading comic books
and he's
certain that these are taken from real
so
if you take like greek mythology and
like he
starts to realize with all kind of like
historical
mythology into comic books and like uh
just fiction
um there's always like archetypes
they're always the same type of
archetype and it's whether you're
talking about gods whether you're
talking about
um like you said superheroes were to
where they're always the same type of
archetype
so he's like this is taken from real
[ __ ] so he's convinced there is
someone out there that really exists
that is a superhero like it's not made
up
like they they're all too familiar from
thousands of years ago until now
so he makes it his life's mission okay
okay to find a superhero
in real life okay which is bruce willis
okay
so um the reason he thinks is bruce
willis
is because there's a massive train crash
and bruce was
the only survivor not a scratch
hundreds of people die on this train
bruce was has not like struck scratch
this is the first one this is him
unbreakable so just goes from there he
meets bruce willis and he's trying to
make
figure out that he to prove to him he's
basically like you're a superhero
bro and i'm going to prove it to you and
it just the whole movie is just bruce
willis
trying to figure out that he's a
superhero and it's
such a good movie okay but such a good
movie bro
i'll watch it but he's like it's good
because it's relatable because like
obviously
he can't fly and [ __ ] do you know what i
mean yeah he's not it's not
outlandish yeah yeah yeah it's like oh
[ __ ] he's like oh you're strong
but he's like someone else could be that
strong yeah but no one else is
that strong but it's not like you're
lifting buildings and [ __ ] you know what
i mean yeah yeah
another human can do but he shouldn't be
able to yes it makes sense
so it's great it's great okay and the
plot twists at the end and stuff like
that and then
yeah it's fantastic so in terms of the
order of watching it because you know
some people
some some people like the [ __ ] with the
order in it like star wars yeah exactly
no it
goes in order so unbreakable split glass
okay say no more
because like i said i've only seen split
once
and did you know that thingy with the
queen's gambit yeah she was in split
oh yeah she is the main girl from a
split
she's got herself a little resume in it
thumb i didn't know i did queen's gab is
a show
queen's gambit is a show yeah you know
she's um
i think she's like half argentinian so
she speaks
spanish bro wow she looks white white as
well
she speaks spanish i watch an interview
like after i watched
um queen's gambit and i was like oh wow
okay she's making money now
yeah she's got a good resume yeah she
does um so yeah
obviously split uh yeah unbreakable
this guy yeah sorry the guy that i
wouldn't be surprised if i'm not
shameless
whatever his name is yeah yeah took some
inspiration from that guy it's
unbreakable because that sounds
too familiar okay say no more um
and also did you say he's been married
five times yes he's got married five
times the easy ass they couldn't take
the trauma in there
they couldn't take it they had to have
to lock him off yeah at this time it was
when he also you married for the fifth
time yeah
and he won the lottery one almost a
million euros
wow the luckiest luckiest man world's
unluckiest luckiest man that's crazy and
he's still alive he's 91 by the way
he was born on the 14th of june 1929
he's still alive
that's crazy bro [ __ ] that is wild
fair play fair play
both world wars he's born in the 20s
when was the first world war oh i don't
know second one was 45
i think first of all was earlier maybe i
don't know oh earlier
you're going to say earlier than world
war ii i was going to slap you bro
come on don't make these don't make it
out like titties man i'm stupid
um i haven't actually i've never done it
fair play i
don't know my history's not good like
that i feel like it's like the 19 early
1910s
um speaking of world war ii did you know
that hitler did not start
the nazi movement he didn't invent being
a nazi who did
[Music]
there was i'm going to butcher this
someone's going to comment this
um and just you [ __ ] butchered this
um
there was a socialist movement
in uh germany yeah called
the something like the
oh i can't remember had nazi in it i'm
sure like neo-nazi socialist
something something um but basically
hitler worked for like the government or
something like that
i'm going to butcher this yeah that's
fine this is terrible i'm going to put
the pieces together yeah yeah
so hitler basically worked for the
government or something yeah and he was
tasked
to go out and he's here and there the
government are hearing whispers about
this socialist movement
um in germany or he's not from germany
in um
either in germany or where he was born
in uh what's that place near germany
called
that arnold schwarzenegger's from does
it begin with a
austria austria austria so i think
hitler's from austria as well okay so
either in austria germany can't remember
which one but basically they need to
um like disband this group basically and
their ideologies
so he's goes out there and meets them
and obviously
tries to disband this whole [ __ ]
[ __ ] this uprise against
the government um and he just gets lost
in it bro like a cult
he gets finessed in there and yeah and
he actually becomes the leader of
their little group and then he
runs the whole thing blew up oh wow it
was the whole thing it started off as
like a little thing
it wasn't even like he was the president
or whatever and then just decided to
start this whole nazi movement now he
was
a guy who got chirps into this little
cult and then
i don't know what i don't know what
happened from there hop skip jump later
man's running things
start on world wars oh wow um but yeah
crazy bro crazy cool so um
would you rather would you rather kick a
baby
oh god or take a right hook from mike
tyson in his prime
are you sure he's going to pick your
poison cuz that's this is dark but
a right hook to the draw where yeah
your least favorite place to take a
right hook i'm assuming
in his prime his prime how hard you have
to kick the baby
oh that's a good question it is a valid
question
um you have to boot the baby
not as hard as you can but like
you need to you okay i need to get some
elevation you need
you need to kick it like
you need to kick it hard enough that a
football would hit the crossbar
from like the so if you've got like the
perfect it's not
necessarily the penalty spot but it's
like what's the lightest wherever you
can be
obviously not scooping the ball but
wherever you can be
to kick the ball as light as possible
but it still has to hit the crossbar
so wherever you need to be to make that
happen to get the perfect angle
yeah but it has to be hard enough to hit
the crossbar so that's not necessarily
that's nothing near as hard as you can
but it's it's
got weight on it that's very hard
considering the weight of a baby and the
weight of a ball like oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah i'm murking to you
yeah if the it would it cross that's
elevation
survival rate yeah so it's probably 50
50. it's less than that
if you hit in the ribs it's
it has to lick off the crossbar oh no it
just has to
kiss the crossbar so if you get
perfectly
under the ball you can hit it yeah when
you hit a crossbar without hitting it
very hard
no yes well that's a ball though i know
but i'm just saying
do you just have to hit the baby that
hard
i'm not gonna no it's not gonna work
because i have to hit the baby harder no
the baby don't have to hit the crossbar
i know but i have to hit the baby high
enough so it's hard enough so it's got
the elevation of a crossbar
no what i'm saying is okay imagine a
football
okay hitting the crossbar yeah imagine
if i said bro so that's how hard
that's how hard you need to keep the
baby i thought you're saying i have to
kick the baby so it can reach like that
no
i'm saying however i'm hot yeah however
hard you would kick the football
is how hard you have to kick this baby
and further back from the penalty spot
no wherever you need it to be it's not
that hard then
yeah that's what i'm trying to say okay
i'll kick the baby
yeah that's not that hard that's not
that hard i'm not securing a bang
a right hook bang from mike tyson in his
prime or kicker you
as long as it's not my you or you that i
know yeah that's a random you randomly
i'm kicking you
i'm kicking you 100 cool coco what are
you doing uh
hmm it's a good question
would i tempt this you i mean i wouldn't
do it with joy but it probably depends
on mike's mood on the day oh my god
fam have you seen an in there's an
interview of mike tyson
have you seen it where he says he says
to the like reporter i'm gonna [ __ ] you
too you love me
no bro there is an interview here
this guy's violent in his prime violence
yeah he was drinking a lot he found he
was in all sorts i think this is just as
he got out of jail actually
where he's he's out he's doing like a
press conference and one of the guys
says something i don't know what he says
but he's he goes after him he goes after
him
and he's like bro um what did he say he
says stuff like
um um
he says like obviously don't talk [ __ ]
you punk white boy he's like don't talk
to you [ __ ] point white boy
you [ __ ] point why boy and he's like
um that's joking he says you [ __ ]
white boy and he's like
i'm gonna [ __ ] you he's like is that
he's like i'm gonna [ __ ] you i'm gonna
[ __ ] you until you love me you hoe
you whole you white hoe and he's like
yeah you're scared now you scared the
real man i gotta [ __ ] you till you love
me
it's the scariest thing you can say
because you imagine if he says that to
me
i'm gonna [ __ ] you until you love me wow
where did that come from yeah
wow that's a threat that's a threat
fam from mike tyson i'm a paparazzi guy
my camera's shaking i don't bang weights
like that a man said you're scared now
in front of the real man oh and your
peers are just
just looking at you what are you gonna
do what are you gonna do
you can't chat [ __ ] back bro you can't
say nothing back oh my
mike if he's in that mood he's not
rocking my jaw
he can never be in that mood and then
say come here so i can rock your jaw
he'll kill me he'll knock it off he will
not at this point it's either me or the
baby
someone's gonna die and it has to be
he's not even
he doesn't even know what's going on
yeah
he's done for he's done for
i'll talk him harder than he needs to
i'm too old
punt never you because i he doesn't want
to have to go for that kind of rehab
yeah
i might as well just x him off poor
thing
he's not swinging my jaw oh my god mike
tyson's vicious
oh how man used to fight him i don't
know i don't get him
there's a he's got a documentary on sky
sports i've not watched the year but
i've recorded it i really want to watch
it i really want to watch it
just about what like his fights in his
bra it's all about his prime stuff
i think just after he came out pen um it
just shows
like all these major fights and like how
he's
how he was treated and how his mental
state was outside of the ring as well
yeah i've done a list i've listened to a
lot of his interviews and stuff like
that he's been on like podcasting he's
got his own podcast as well
yeah yeah um his stuff's dark bro he i
don't know if i've said this on here
before he told joe rogan that he gets
like
a arouse to the thought of hurting
someone did i tell you that
i may have seen it because i have seen
his interview on joe rogan
yeah i don't remember if i remember i
remember hearing that you know you could
have said that i just know it was
concerning
i don't you could joe when silence gets
aroused by hurting people
he's like you know joe was like
basically this was when he was preparing
for the roy jones fight
okay and he was like because before he's
had mike tyson on twice the first time
he was completely like i don't like to
think about the past i don't want my
kids fighting i don't like this is this
then he got signed up for the roy jones
fight so obviously training he's getting
the hunger back
okay and he's like oh how do you feel
like in the stuff and he's like how do
you feel when you imagine yourself like
fighting him and all this stuff
yeah and he's like you can tell he
doesn't know that's not
normal what he's about to say yeah
because he's like oh bro it's just like
when i think about getting in the ring
and i think about hurting him and like
all this stuff he's like when i think of
he's like the thought of hurting people
gives me sexual arousal like it makes me
want to like come
he said it's orgasmic like i get really
turned on
like i actually get like aroused by the
thought of like hurting people
and then the room's silent for like 10
seconds some massacres [ __ ]
bro and you can tell he doesn't know
that that's not right yeah
and he's like yeah what is that joe why
why do i feel like that and she was like
i don't know if those answers i don't
have those answers i don't know don't
ask
me i'm not a clinician you need to see
a doctor now i'll tell them
cancel the fight cancel the fight
because he's not ready
he's sick in his head you say right wow
man said it turns me on and he doesn't
know that other people don't feel that
way
that's how you know it's true because he
said it was such bravado and he's asking
why do i feel like that he just said it
haphazardly bro
you can't say stuff like that you can't
on cam
i was thinking oh i was scared for roy
jones then luckily the fight was trash
but
um i was thinking that if i was roy
jones and i heard him say that i'll lock
up the heart
so you can't pay me enough i'm not
getting in the ring with him my city
gets turned on by the thought of hurting
me damn that means he has to hurt me
that means he can't wait to hurt me nah
not me guys
imagine he rocks your jaw now no the
right hook thing now no
james i haven't bashed in a week i
haven't had a wank in a week
i can't wait your jaw's spinning your
jaw is
i'll never eat it right again i'll never
eat right again this podcast will get
locked
you will literally be in a vegetarian
i'll be there and you'll be talking and
i'll be there
[Music]
[Laughter]
bro oh my days no i'll have a nurse just
here
just wipe in my mouth like my man from
oh what's that movie called
um the one with kevin hart brian
cranston
um i [ __ ] love that movie the um
the upside the upside down
[Music]
[Laughter]
we'll get initial spike because people
want to see what happens
they'd want to know what happened give
it two weeks they're like now this guy's
done
someone get him off the camera bro if
you're like this for two weeks in a row
never like that yeah that's kind of yeah
sponsorships everywhere week two dog
[ __ ]
this is this is going on the nurses
don't want to be here anymore
and i'm just like rabbity rap and then
that just wheels me out
you just sign up
[Music]
now oh my days no hilarious
oh my god yeah the baby has to get it
yeah the baby's gonna have to go bro i
can't live my life like that
oh that's hilarious vegetative statement
um speaking of fighters
backstories uh francis and ghana won his
fight yesterday as you see
i didn't see the fight i don't really i
haven't seen the fight yet i saw the
knockout
i haven't seen the fight yet this have
you seen any of his fights i've shown
you some of his fights
maybe g but i don't the name doesn't
ring a bell to me i don't follow him
he's a warrior i don't follow ufc like
that
okay at all he up into this point
the longest fight he'd ever had was one
minute and 11 seconds
that rings the bell you've cause you've
definitely told me that before he knocks
this is the heavyweight champion
champion now yeah yeah
yeah he was on joe rogan a few weeks ago
okay his life story is the most
fascinating
thing you've ever heard i promise you
that now fascinating thing buckle up
because this is going to be a long one
oh i'm here for fam i'm here
fascinating i'm here for it
so france isn't gonna yeah yeah so man
was born
in cameroon yes um and he
he grew up poor even for cameroon
standards he got poor found
he had to um so his father
was like an alcoholic abuser so his mom
and i got divorced
okay and i think he had to live with his
grandmother for a few years
for whatever reason his mom couldn't
look after himself to live with his
grandma
and they had no money so he had to work
in the sand mines
for his entire school life there was
sand mines period
what's the sand mines femme i don't know
go to cameroon and find out i don't know
um so he had to work in sandwiches
digging sand okay
um went from when he was from his entire
school life
so basically from i think he said he
started there at age 10 and he was doing
it up into the
left score like 17. and he had to do
that to pay his so in cameroon you have
to pay school tuition
throughout school is not free there so
um
that's what he used to pay school
tuition so and his school was six miles
away from his yard
so every morning he'd have to walk six
miles to school
and six miles back and he said um
man didn't have uh food or money to eat
so he used to have like he had breakfast
so sometimes he wouldn't even eat his
breakfast he'd bring his breakfast to
school to have for lunch
because he knew he'd be too hungry he
said on the day he'd eat his breakfast
at home
he'd have to leave school early because
he felt like he was going to pass out if
he didn't leave school he's like i'm not
making it to the end of school
and then walking six miles home i'll die
before i get there so he'd have to
save his breakfast walk to school wait
until lunch time then eat his breakfast
and then eat again when he gets home
long for him long for him
he said he didn't have any friends in
school because he was so poor there was
no transactional like um
i guess the culture over there is
obviously sharing um that's an african
thing isn't it
you must share yeah yeah share i think
it depends on i keep kicking this thing
i think it depends on
[Music]
i don't know kind of if you like enter
when you say sharing
in terms of what exactly just like food
especially
yeah i guess i guess like it's very um
like food is like
in english culture it's not common to
just give people food
do you know what i mean like if people
like i'll be surprised if someone came
to my yard with food
if someone came to visit me and they're
bringing me food i'd be like
cool thanks but like what also what are
you doing yeah yeah whereas like
african culture like if someone comes to
the yard and brings you rice that that's
normal
normal normal normal yeah yeah okay cool
so yeah basically he was saying in
school
he hasn't he had no friends because he
was so poor
like no one would bother being his
friend because they had nothing he had
nothing to bring to the table
in terms of he couldn't share like all
these men would share sandwiches with
each other and trade and
all this [ __ ] just that kids do
apparently um
but he had nothing so no one would even
bother being his friend i said he didn't
even have a pencil
and he would end up getting kicked out
of school
for the rest of the year because he
couldn't afford like stationery
or books so he'd have to rock up he
ain't got bookie ain't got pen so
teachers just like big man
what are you even doing here um so the
apparently obviously because they're
like there's basically a third world
country there
um you don't they don't provide you with
anything you have to pay for your own
school yeah
you have to pay for your own station
they don't give you anything so if he
ain't got it
there's no point in being there so he
would have to he would have nothing bro
he'll say he grew up no friends
and he used to be upset because he would
think like not upset but he used to be
like
it's dread because these men look down
on me
when their parents like i'm at this
school
because i work so that i i'm at school
getting an education because i work in
the mines
when i'm not at school so i can pay to
come to school these [ __ ]
don't just wake up and get to come to
school yeah and he was like there and
they look down on me like i'm [ __ ] yeah
he's like they're they ain't [ __ ] like
i've earned myself here they've done
nothing to be here
and they look at me like i'm a piece of
[ __ ] yeah um and it gave him like a chip
on the shoulder
so anyway he's living his life and i
think when he was younger he got to try
like boxing
he loved it and he always grew up
thinking i want to be a boxer
but there's literally no gyms he
anywhere in like a
10-15 mile radius of his where he lived
there was not a single gym
not to work out not to box nothing but
he knew
he wanted to be a boxer so bad in his
head he was like i'm going to be a
professional boxer i don't know how
but i'm going to be a professional boxer
one day so like so he just never drank
he's never had a drink in his life
and even when he socialized with friends
and stuff like that and go out and eat
[ __ ] he's
he'd never eat [ __ ] he'd never drink and
they'd be like why is that wrong because
i'm an athlete
is that fun you've never even been to a
gym and he's like yeah but i will
so i want to be ready for when i do
that's how like certain he was he was
going to make it
gang even though he's never even
experienced it he doesn't know where to
start fam
it was very gang so he
decides one day like [ __ ] it um he saved
up loads of money and he's like
i'm i'm leaving cameroon and i'm gonna
find a gym i'm gonna i need to start
this boxing thing now
so he told his family obviously his
family like you're a [ __ ] don't um
you don't know what you're wrong about
you're a [ __ ] though
um and he said [ __ ] it but i need to try
and everyone's like yeah but
he said that apparently there are like a
few famous boxers out of cameroon
that they referenced that it's never
come
to fruition like they've been
professional they've got paid but
financially it's never worked out for a
long time
okay so they have no money now and those
his parents would be like yeah but
these are the only boxes that i've ever
come out of cameroon and look at them
like so why would you go and be a boxer
and stuff like that so he's like this is
just what i want to do bro
every time he said every single time
someone would come to negatives he was
like yeah
but also i'm not gonna live the rest of
my life and never try
so man decided all right cool i need to
get out cameroon he said he'd still at
this point didn't know where he was
going he just knows
i'm getting i can't do this in cameroon
i need to go to europe
so um he says he's got no documents he's
got
no visa he's got nothing so he has to
obviously do it the hard way
it took him 14 months 14 months
to get from cameroon to europe
14 months what
a year and two months to get from
cameroon to europe because
he left cameroon went from cameroon to
nigeria
stayed in nigeria for like a week and
then went across the
went across to niger then from niger
went across the sahara to morocco
man said the journey from niger to
morocco is like 24 hours
but it's like big boy
smuggle human trafficking [ __ ] like he
said you basically there's like 20 of
you get on the back of his pickup truck
and you have to hold on for dear [ __ ]
life because he's bombing 150 miles an
hour
because if a helicopter sees you it's
done
he said if you fall off you fall off so
man said for 24 hours you're grabbing
onto the side of this truck
as hard as you can he said the cramps in
your hand that you feel are
inexplainable
but you physically can't let go because
this grip is the
your q man literally described it as a
this grip is your grip to life
because if you if you if you let go
you're falling off he said there was a
woman
going wait are they in this pickup truck
they're in the back of the picture is
this pickup truck open yeah
ah open like it you know that where they
put like lock some [ __ ]
just an open pickup truck you have to
hold the [ __ ] on
and he said there was a woman on there
with a baby and she said by the
he said by hour like 12 she literally
was ready to throw a baby of a ball
because she can take anymore
she was ready to get rid of the baby
because she couldn't take it anymore
she couldn't handle it fam so obviously
the other people offered to like have
the baby and stuff
um she was ready to lock it all off
that's how bad it was he said it's the
worst 24 hours you'll ever experience
he said this grip fan 24 hours 24 hours
of it
and he said because um you've all got a
squeeze on this thing you can't bring
any luggage
and you can only bring hardly any water
and you're in the sahara [ __ ] desert
he said you're only about to bring like
a bottle of water like three four hours
in your water's done
so you just gotta firm it for the rest
of the time and he said at night it gets
freezing as well
freezing at night hottest you've ever
experienced in the day
coldest you've ever experienced at night
they said the whole day was a [ __ ]
mess
worst day ever did you make it to
morocco and then um
jorah was like so what's morocco like
thinking like and he's like
bro we're just warming up morocco he
said for an
immigrant morocco is literally hell hell
it's hell fam morocco is where you need
to go if you're going to try and get to
europe
uh i think it's like a morocco to spain
um
so he gets the morocco right
so the basically the plan is you get to
morocco
um you save up money for like a raft
these ones get like
rafts that go in swimming pools fam they
get like baby rafts
and they all squeeze up in there and you
have to buy some paddles by raft and you
get on the ocean and you go
he said but you're in the south of
morocco you need to make your way up
through the deserts up to the north of
morocco
and to get into the north of morocco
there's like a um
there's a bit that's owned by spain okay
so you need to get in here to get
available to go on the ocean to go
to spain so um he said that
but to get past that there's an 11 mile
long fence
with barbed wire everywhere um 11 miles
11 miles and he said it's people's job
people take like scouting jobs
where one person will scout for days at
a time just sleeping living in the
desert
looking for weaknesses in this fence and
he says you pick a day you pick a time
you have to learn the like
like spy [ __ ] yeah you have to learn the
rotations the shift patterns
how you're going to get in everything
and then on one day everyone picks a day
and you go and man said you'll never
believe he said there's hundreds of
people
there hundreds of people waiting he said
you'll never believe
when people have a common goal how crazy
is that you can have like 200 people
in dead silence in sitting in dead
silence
he says you think it's impossible if you
go out tomorrow
gather 200 people and get them to be
quiet impossible for days
for days not for like 10 minutes days
no one makes a peep he said everyone was
able to do it
crazy so wow you pick a day
you all get together you decide right
11 o'clock on friday we're busting
through this fence
and then once you get through the fence
everyone scatters finds places in the
town to hide out and stuff like that
and then you'll find time to congregate
together another day to get this boat
and
go off and the boat obviously only
carol's like carries out five six people
because it's a little baby team so
you're getting you'll find your little
groups
and your your guy from your goal so man
said it took i think it took him two or
three tries
to bust through the gate first time man
got caught up in barbed wire fam
he said he didn't even know what baghdad
was so his bus through there
he's fallen in like a pit of barbed wire
and man said he wanted to just lay there
in it because he said
when you land in it you get pricked a
little bit yeah but it's when you try
and get out that it starts tearing your
[ __ ] up
so he said um you fall in you land and
he was like [ __ ]
but he said i have to get out because if
i don't get out these men are going to
kill me
literally kill me so he has to get out
and he said he's bleeding everywhere
he's losing blood like crazy
got out and he said because he's the
biggest one they
think that the big ones are the leaders
for some reason
so he said they'll treat me as a leader
and they want to kill all the leaders
to set an example so he said if they
catch me it's [ __ ] they'll set they'll
probably put my [ __ ] head on the
spike or something
it's [ __ ] for me if they catch me
because i'm the biggest one here so he
said he drapes himself out
and he said he didn't want to go
hospital they said after like a while
like a day
he's like i'm losing a lot i have to go
to the hospital because he knew the
police were going to be scouting
hospitals
because loads of people got taken and
injured and all that stuff so he's like
[ __ ] it i have to go he went hospital he
said in the middle of himself getting
stitched up they found him and
draped him they didn't let him finish
nothing draped him
arrested him put him in a jail um
move they'd drive you all the way down
to the south of morocco again
and just drop you off in the desert drop
you off the desert it's a [ __ ] off home
then you have to make your way all the
way back up to the north again he said
that happened twice
on the third time he managed to make it
through the fence
yeah bro you make it through the fence
you um another 24 hours on a thing no no
not sahara that's from niger to morocco
oh say no more
if i get dropped back off there hold on
i'm queen
man i'm right fan
oh my days okay say no more so drop you
over to the south of morocco
yeah yeah yeah yeah then you've got to
travel all the way up to north again
yeah yeah yeah
still [ __ ] horrible of course um
because this is on foot now
across our country oh on foot no water
no food no nothing
he's a warrior he's a [ __ ] warrior go
up to the north
bastard defense again so anyway on the
third time he gets through
so now he's in uh live and living living
comes together um same thing find some
friends
get a raft pick a day
they set off but there's coastal guards
every time of course
to catch these [ __ ] first time got
caught and he said the first time
he was um he said everyone has to pick a
captain
uh he said the first time you realize
when you've been there for a while how
desperate you get
because the first captain had been there
for a while his his first ever captain
when he went on the raft he had been
there for a while when they got caught
the captain said there was four of them
the captain said just tell when they
catch you just say there was three of
you he was a big man but there's four of
us he said [ __ ] this i'm swimming
and he was like oh i promise you you'll
die do not swim the captain was like
oh big man i'm not going back like i'm
not going back i will [ __ ] swim
that's how desperate i am i will [ __ ]
swim there i don't care i'll take my
i'll i'll take my chances with the
sharks and the waves bro
they're not bringing me back and he
remembers he remembers thinking like
what the actual [ __ ] like it's not that
deep g
like it's not that deep
let's get catch we'll start again
like it's a game you know i'm not
swimming yeah and man said he couldn't
swim in it mm-hmm
so he said francis francis said he he
can't swim so he's not that's never
going to be
for him yeah yeah so um he said
basically
but obviously when they catch you in the
boat same thing g
arrested south of morocco stop you off
in the desert
[ __ ] off yeah so he said then you have
to break through the fence
again bro long story short
it he did this nine times this fence
thing this fence thing
nine times [ __ ] sometimes you get caught
at the vents
sometimes you get caught in the raft
sometimes you get caught on roads
um so bro it's long how they didn't dup
him
is beyond me crazy i don't know but um
i think he's not a violent guy so he's
not really fighting anyone yeah yeah
yeah
um he's the nicest guy bro and then so
he said on the last last last time
he um he
he mentally was at the point where the
guy the first captain was at when he
said i'm [ __ ]
swimming he said france said bro i
promise you i'm making it this time
and he said to the the people that want
to go with him
he's like because he was the captain now
i'm captain now
i'm about to say that he said well he
was the captain he's
told them like big man we're not coming
back
so whatever you need to do do because we
ain't coming back
like i promise you i'm not coming back
he said he was tapped at this point he's
uh i'm done here like
i'm making it to spain so fam they get
in the raft
um go and go and go and go and go in
and apparently once you get across like
the middle point and you're kind of in
spanish waters
you can call the red cross and the red
cross will save you
um but they need good reason so
they ask you when you call them they ask
you like how did they call him how's
that he had a mobile
oh yeah so they get [ __ ] whilst they're
in there for however month months
they managed to get [ __ ] okay and he
still uh before he left he left all of
his money with his sister
okay he told his sister don't ask me who
i am but there's going to be times i'm
going to call you intermittently
and you're going to have to run and pee
wherever i am so you're going to have to
send me money in morocco you're going to
see me in spain
so um he had money to eat and stuff like
that
but so he had a phone call the red cross
and they were like oh is there children
on board is there like women on board
he said yep yep yep there's kids there's
babies fam
like they're gonna drown save us save us
yeah
he said yeah the red cross came up saved
them but then they put you in prison
in spain obviously
but then you go through court
proceedings everything and they just
basically kick you out
homeless in spain because if your
country doesn't have extradition laws
you
um obviously don't get they can't
they've got nowhere to send you yeah
they kind of introduce you back to your
country they can't extract you back to
your country so they just keep you there
that's just like a homeless guy so
dropped off in spain
uh was there for a little while made his
way to france because they speak
french in cameroon of course so made his
way to france
found a gym started boxing obviously
wants to become a professional boxer
but he's homeless in in france um he's
got no
passport no nothing so he said he
started training and one of the guys let
him train for free at this gym he said i
want to be a boxer i want to be a boxer
a man said um big man i'm going to be
honest with you
you'll never make it as a boxer because
boxing is like a white collar sport
it's like very upper class and you don't
even have a passport
like getting you in the circuit for
boxing is going to be too hard it's
going to take years bro you're going to
need documents you need jobs you're
going to need
something you're going to have to get
your [ __ ] together yeah before we can
even get you on the circuit yes yeah
but at the time is i think he's about
2012 or something
mma was illegal in france okay so he
said we can get you in the mma ring
and you can [ __ ] some people up um and
you'll be cash in hand
you're homeless bro like you need the
money this you can make 500 here 1000
there
let's just get you a few fights and get
some money in your pocket and then we
can
sort boxing out later once you've got
your [ __ ] together but for now mma is
your thing
yeah and he was like my [ __ ] mma i
know this stuff but then he tried it a
couple times alright cool
they saw that with a couple of fights
won a couple tournaments got some p
and it was he said fam fast forward
man's heavyweight champion in the ufc
now
this is a big deal from cameroon to
ufc champion he says he goes back to
cameroon and everyone's like nah
nah he made it he made it he actually
made it what a story
story of stories people live different
lives
bro story of stories 14 months doing
that
so his final destination was france i'm
just human final destination was france
he fights out france to this day yeah
wow but he's like in america he's in
france he's all over
is he fights out of france in a sense
that is that his second like nationality
um i don't in terms of legality yeah
um it will say like when he i don't know
where he is like document wise
but when when it comes to fighting it
will say because you know it says like
their name and it says where they fight
from
he says paris france okay okay okay so
that's where his
gym is in france um
props to the guy that let him train for
free big props he loves that guy
he says like i owe this guy so much
props he literally came in there as a
homeless person
and he said the guy gave him 50 euros he
said can i come and train with you and
he was like uh i'll have to talk to the
main coach but
uh if he says go it's cool you can come
in and train with us he said he
gave him 50 euros and he said he spent
that 50 euros on boxing gear he didn't
buy food without muffin he said he was
so excited
to come back and train that he went to
the shop with his 50 euros
bought socks bought boxing shoes bought
some shorts
and bought a towel and a vest he said he
couldn't afford nothing else
i couldn't afford wraps gonna afford
gloves nothing so just went there with
what he could afford with the 50
and he was i said i'm ready to train
this is what i left cameroon for
that's a that's a life to live bro what
story to tell your kids
bro i mean that could motivate anyone
anyone
anywhere he says the boys in cameroon
literally takes so much motivation from
it
to start their own [ __ ] because the
cameroon is not like that
yeah it's got like it's like the every
african mentality like the
the old school african mentality times a
million yeah yeah because they also have
[ __ ] all there
yeah so they've got no one to draw
motivation from um
[Music]
so yeah for him saying he wants to be a
boxer was basically
you telling your mom like i guess i've
got to be a youtuber
yeah like it's like shut up yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
but not even telling her now yeah like
telling her in nigeria
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but yeah
crazier story
crazier story that is that will give any
single human being motivation to do
whatever they want
anything that's crazy bro 14 months nine
times through the fence
holding on to the truck for 24 hours
does he know if the
the mum and the kid made it he ain't got
a clue bro
man said she wanted to dash to you after
what 10 hours or something
that's scary bro 24 hours i can't
believe that bro i can't believe that
crazy
i can't believe that crazy
that's mind-boggling man said that when
he thinks back it
he also can't believe it he said the
story's so unreal that
even though he lived it he still thinks
it wasn't real
wow nuts the things people go literally
just about to say that the things people
go through just because man want to do
2-2 jab
no send me back to the mines the sand
mines you know send me back to the
sandwich i'm not doing ah
man it just shows you anyone can succeed
if you actually
are [ __ ] determined bro 100
man said i'm not going back this is it
this is it i'm not going back bro 100
because he said the last time the reason
he got so [ __ ] motivated the last
time
was because his boy had messaged him
saying let's go uh i think
about a week before something that
stopped him from linking his boy i can't
remember
but his boy said let's go they were in
submarines
whilst they were in morocco the time so
obviously he took him nine times
let's say uh a week before the ninth
time yeah
his boy message and said i've got a raft
together i've got this crew we all love
you you're good captain
come on our raft let's go mm-hmm and he
said i can't remember this bit but it's
something to do with maybe like the bus
routes
there were loads of police around and
stuff like that it was just too hot okay
so he was like uh
i might have to skip this one because
it's just too hot i'll
i probably won't make it off the bus
yeah um
and then about a week later
uh he found out through the grapevine
and he was like oh yeah boy you made it
you know and he's like what is that your
boy your boy he's in spain
and he was like no no no no
no no no no no that's when he was like
no [ __ ] no
get get a raft two two paddle let's go
we're going today
[ __ ] this no i'm going to play now he
was like no [ __ ] way
that is [ __ ] let's go [ __ ] he would
have been pissed he didn't go
live it live it live it that's what he
he said it was still hot
when he decided to go he was like i
don't care i literally do not care i'm
not going back
we're going to spain today bro i can't
stay in hell any day any a day longer i
can't
i can't do it man said i'm not going
back
ah
that's amazing it is amazing it's
amazing it is amazing
um yeah bros and he didn't even speak
english when he started the ufc the
thing is i was going to ask that but i
was thinking
maybe in cameroon like when he was
younger he
[Music]
he he learned himself he took a couple
he said he had they do teach english in
cameroon he said
but he said um yeah when he first
started using he didn't speak any
english
and he said there's a time when joe
rogan even said like he interviewed
francis after his first win
president didn't have a clue what you're
saying didn't have a clue
to now a few years later he's on the pod
i mean the whole thing he struggled with
a couple
words like he didn't know what barred
wire was so joel rose i was called
barbed wire
but after he didn't under he didn't
quite hear him and he said i call it
babaru
is that for time
so he's appointing me you know where you
can tell derek is thinking
i can't say babadoo anymore because he's
getting confident with it but it's been
so long he's been so long
and he was like he said he was like oh
yeah the barbed wire
he didn't want to say by the way it's
not bubba dude it's barbed wire
so he said oh the barbed wire and then
france you could tell francis
yeah barbed wire yeah
my chest my guys
um what a story sick story what a guy
bro yeah man um i love that complete
change of topic hit me i didn't tell you
i have the worst i need to see a dentist
i need need to see a dentist
where where are we wisdom tooth oh
bottom left
oh bro i've had my wisdom teeth for
years right
and i've needed to get them taken out
for years as well because they're always
like biting my cheek and [ __ ]
giving me issues always bro but i'm just
too scared so i never get them taken out
you've got me like using my tongue to
check my teeth now
bro i woke up last week saturday
ting was swollen my face was swollen
and i'll say kid oh it's infected which
has happened before
when we lived together as well one of my
wisdom teeth got infected it might have
been the same one actually
um and i just went there they gave me
antibiotics and it sorted itself out
so i was like i'm i had antibiotics at
home so i was like
i'll just take out boy x if it doesn't
go down in a few days then i'll i'll
figure it out
check antibiotics the swelling went down
a couple days later but the pain never
stopped
um so i was thinking it's not infected
because it's not getting worse
the pain is exactly the same all day
every day
um so um
i checked i had like a proper check like
what's going on bro
the tooth is growing
it's like it's i think how to explain so
obviously you've got your wisdom teeth
it's long so not long up
long like this way length yeah widthwise
yeah yeah so it's
um the end is starting to break through
now
but it's breaking through at a point
where my gum isn't there anymore
like you know at the very very very very
back where it all connects your gum your
cheek your throat they'll connect
bro it's growing in my [ __ ] cheek and
it's
split through my cheek and there is a
[ __ ] hole in my cheek
that is just bleeding fam it's just
bleeding every day i've got disappointed
on wednesday i don't think i'm gonna
make it
[Laughter]
every day's bleeding i haven't eaten in
days
i've just been eating on this side and
i'm just there just like
because i can't even close my teeth i've
been sleeping with a gum shield
like bro come [ __ ] i've been sleeping
with a gum shield
the gum shows city seven rugby
that's hilarious your best
everything it's bad wow
it's bad so yeah like i can't point on
wednesday but
i'm thinking i don't know if i'm gonna
make it bro and since last saturday
since last week saturday damn it's been
a week in a bit now
it's bad bro jesus it's horrible that
doesn't sound like
i've been cleaning it like there's no
one's doing it have you was there
anything that prompted it
or is it just the growth of just the
growth i think if you look at it i won't
show you but if you look at it
it's like the growth it's just [ __ ]
broken through bro and it's just like a
hole in my face
have you like changed up toothpaste or
something not injured what two faces you
use
that could help oh in terms of helping
yeah yeah it sounds like uh
just like colgatey i don't know try oral
bg or sensodyne
yeah i know this is a weird topic sorry
guys but yeah i use um
oral b all the time because i there was
a point where i had
very this was before i moved into my new
gaff
so it probably was tail end of last
lockdown
my teeth were very [ __ ] sensitive oh
yeah
did i tell you you may have it just
happened one day i slept and i woke up
and
hot food and cold stuff bro nightmare
teeth i've had sensitive for years
gone horrible gone horrible i couldn't
chew properly
if i i couldn't use mouthwash or i
couldn't if you even when you're rinsing
your mouth with water after brushing
your teeth yeah i couldn't lap
yeah i just have to throw it in my mouth
and throw it back out again
because fam it's like every single every
single tooth was so
sensitive well it's horrible sensitive
teeth is a nightmare that's a curse and
that's when i changed it up too yeah
yeah yeah to be fair i've had sensitive
a few times yeah
um but yeah i need to get it sorted bro
because the cheek is never gonna heal
until this [ __ ] tooth comes out yeah
yeah yeah yeah um so hopefully they sort
of started out for me
on wednesday um but i was thinking like
den is ah being a dentist is such a
weird thing and cena does i never see
dentists
i can't remember the last time i saw it
i need to i need to as well um
but i was thinking this is stupid but i
was thinking like
obviously being a dentist is like or
having a dentist [ __ ] with your mouth is
like a very invasive thing
of course and you don't know what
they're doing because it's not an
everyday practice now someone fingered
up in your mouth yeah
and then i was thinking at what point
would you stop a dentist
if he's getting inappropriate and taking
it too far all that so yeah like this
thing
so so you're in the dentist chair you're
just there
yeah and just mouth swinging and then
rolling and they got that sucker in
there
hovering out there and you're just there
and then he's obviously messing with
your tongue
yeah and he's using that metal thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and he
like obviously opens it up and then he
puts a thing the finger on the tongue
and you're just like oh okay
and then he slides it down and you're
like
and you're thinking this is normal like
hopefully i won't gag
yeah i don't want to i don't want to be
the guy that gag
and then he just keeps it there and then
you look at him and he's staring at you
fam
in your eyes he ain't even looking in
your mouth
he's staring in your eyes and he's just
there like he's got a mask here in it
you just see the eye right now
what do you do fam what do you do
because you can't even talk at that
point firm you're just standing in your
mouth
and he's just staring at you family he's
loving this and you're just sprawling
spread out in the chair you can't bite
him nothing and you're just there like
is this normal dentist practice must
have changed because
bro i don't remember this eyes will be
going
i wouldn't know what to do i'd have to
close my mouth i'd have to bite his
finger
yeah sorry i'm sorry sorry sorry sorry
am i just there like with the bite lip
yeah
but you can't see yeah i never know
what's going on you just see this i
started to squint because he's happy
do you know how that's that's tapped
because i don't even look at barbers in
their face you know when they're lining
you up in the front
and they have to come around and look it
kind of look at you but they're looking
at your hair
found my eyes i don't want them in my
face
i don't want barbers in my face my
barber sent for me in public one time
for some reason i think i was
daydreaming i stared him in his eye when
he was here
and he stopped you know what you've met
yeah he was like why are you staring at
me
and i was like what he's like why are
you staring me in my eye
why are you staring at me i didn't shop
full my heart would have beat
i wanted to fight him bro i wonder
oh i went off i never know a [ __ ]
staring at you but shut up
shut up and your voice gets high
shut up [ __ ] and you know you get
hot
prickles from the sweat and the fear
nah also barbers when obviously because
they go around you and obviously all
barbers have like the armrest here the
arm rests on the chairs
i'm always like this yeah when they're
walking obviously you have to be close
to yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'm pretty sure most men
try and keep their elbows yeah
they just feel their balls brush like oh
this is so wrong i try and keep detected
as much as i can when i got my haircut
the other day
barbara was invasive with my ear as well
you know what he's doing this sweet
thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah man's finger
was like here oh up at my ear and it's
just like
oh my god i felt like a yak my head just
dangling
you knew he loved the power it's such a
power play
it's such a powerful because we're
vulnerable yeah you're very
very swings my head just like shut up
swings my head to the left and i have to
sit there and take it hold that you
can't do anything about you have to sit
there and take it
we're so vulnerable oh it's unbelievable
[ __ ] ridiculous but um let's do a
family finisher yeah jesus um
hi guys love your podcast addicted
question i've been seeing a guy on and
off for three years
the sex is phenomenal but the past year
he's been struggling to maintain an
erection oh god so first
first he blamed it on the fact that i
only come to him
for a quick drive by aka a quickie
so i love that time by the way i drive
by i like that so i tried to give him
i tried to give him more time then he
said he can't use condoms which is a no
for me because i've got a kid already
and then he had then sorry and then i
had to always give him head
to keep him hard or would or he would go
down on me
now i feel like we have to do a lot of
freaky stuff in order for him to keep
him temporary
temporarily hard is it me
yes
see you next week actually is like not
even in the way that she thinks it is
her
but it is her the fact that she's in my
opinion
yeah the fact that she said like it
starts off
for starters he hates the condoms that's
relatable
all guys hate condoms but that's
obviously going to be a turn off this is
the fact that it's like
cool like he can't say it hard for the
naan
so you have to give him brains can't
stay hard from the brains anymore
they have to do the next freaky thing
have to do the next freaking next
freaking like
it's not you pers as a person yeah
but it's just like he he's pretty much
the same as
the last guy that we had that i was
suffering with this or the last
uh message that we had from a girl who's
struggling her man
kind of thing he was and it turns out he
was looking for that little freaky noise
yeah
it's just the sex you guys are having is
not what he wants
but he might not he doesn't necessarily
want to tell you like
this is actually what i need so maybe
they're trying to take baby steps
so that like it's like yeah it's kind of
like a no-brainer if like
if you're noticing that the requirements
for his hard-on
are getting crazier and crazier it's
like this is probably where he wanted to
be
from day one yeah and just maybe the
excitement of some new poem
was what kept him hard in the first
place but it's just like that kind of
sex just doesn't do it
yeah like i need this like i'm trying to
get i don't even know bro
like i'm trying to get choked out you're
trying to do all sorts yeah i'm trying
to get crucified out here
i feel like obviously they said um
they've been seeing each other on and
off for three years
oh right yeah i didn't even hear that
three is a long time as well a long time
and i feel like
if you're seeing each other on and off
for three years the parts where they're
off he's obviously [ __ ] other people
right yeah assuming she's probably off
she's probably [ __ ] other people so
in terms of the earlier stages
the sex would have been fine she said
the sex is phenomenal but this past year
so it's in the third year of this on and
off yeah and she struggled to maintain
an erection
um first he blamed it on the fact that i
only come to him for a quickie okay
so my my assumption
is that during the off periods he's
had different type of sex yeah that's
working yeah yeah you know because
i think there's a there's a stage in
in someone's in a man's life per se
because obviously it's affected him he
can't get an erection he's hard for him
to get an erection
i feel like there's a stage in a man's
life where sex just isn't sex anymore
and sex is a lot more than just seeing a
woman think i want to [ __ ] you
because i feel like it's a lot more
mental than
than physiological if that makes sense
yeah yeah yeah yeah i have to sometimes
i have to be mentally aroused by you in
terms of the connection that we have
and in terms of how
how i see us in term in like the bed or
anything like
or just not even necessarily just in the
bed but how comfortable i can be around
you
as just me and you you know and if that
doesn't stimulate me mentally
i'm probably not going to get hard for
you yeah that's the thing as well
because
that's that's sorry to get off it's like
that's that's it it actually bodes well
with what he says
so obviously like it's been three years
and he's also complaining about the fact
that one is what you use in johnny's
and two that it's just a drive-by team
yeah so i can see where after three
years of drive-by things
he probably doesn't see you as a
drive-by thing anymore he sees you as
more than that more than that yeah but
you're still playing this role
whereas a drive-by team to him might be
some scabby slag
that just rolls through step over thing
in it just rolls through
just gets nothing on her face and he's
like yeah i'm done
get back in your cup thank you get in
your car i don't want to look at you
he doesn't see you like that yeah so
you're you're you don't fit the
archetype of what
yeah your actions are not what he
mentally is going to arouse him by you
for you it's been a long time you guys
have been seeing he might
say he wants all this freaking [ __ ] like
he might want an event yeah he doesn't
want to drive by quickly with someone
that's been seen for three
years on and off that's a long time man
for a drive by quickie
i'm not gonna get half of that either to
answer users three years
three years and i'm using the dom for a
drive by quickly that's a long time what
like that's like what yeah that's not
watching the same porn for three years
mentally he's not gonna be and it's not
necessarily you
it doesn't mean yeah that's the thing
it's not you as a person it's just a
role you're fulfilling
yeah he doesn't see you in that role
that you're fulfilling he doesn't see
you as his drive by quickie girl he has
to strap
up for three years for three
years he doesn't see you as that person
so that's not gonna turn him on so it's
not surprising that you're the one that
he's saying
i want to try this and can we do this he
sees you as someone
you've been with someone for three years
seeing someone for three years i'm gonna
want to try some freaky [ __ ] too
freaky [ __ ] to keep it spicy you'll have
some
quick drive by exactly like imagine like
that's like
imagine like your wife
only wanted to [ __ ] you as like a
quickie thing it might be a turn on for
the first little bit
if you're at the office and your wife's
like i'll meet me here on your lunch
break
and [ __ ] me you might be like gang
three years later if that's the only way
you guys have been having sex it's not
gonna turn anymore don't message me
anymore
that's gonna be that [ __ ] this is
boring don't message me though it was a
nice little fantasy at first but
it's boring when you get home like you
live together yeah
like yeah boring yeah yeah yeah so it's
not necessarily you
it's not you as a person role you're
fulfilling yeah he clearly sees more
yeah yeah he's not just here for the it
might well in our opinion
he's not just here for this drive-by
team with a dom after singing for three
years and like
yes you've got a kid i understand about
if you've been seeing this guy for three
years on and off granted
do you not feel like you're wasting each
other's time if you don't
kind of move this somewhere you know if
it's just quickies like come on
even you you must know that
you're feeling him a lot more than you
think and vice versa he must know he's
feeling you a lot more than he thinks as
well
well he knows that he's feeding you a
lot more yeah considering he doesn't
just want this because his dick doesn't
just want this yeah right it's just like
what are we doing here it's all
psychological yeah yeah it's all
psychologically
psychological for dudes especially yeah
for dudes fam
it's super super psychological in terms
of like i know for women it's
psychological in terms of getting that
nut
a lot of the time for guys just to even
show up especially at our old age
even just to show up in psychological
psychology just having stress in your
life can be enough to just
get you out of the function yeah and
especially if you're just having
quickies with a dom or someone that
you've known for three
years bro no
that's like what are we literally what
are we doing like a drive-by quickie
with a dub when i picture someone if
someone said to me
picture the girl that just drives by
your house for a quickie and you have to
strap up
i'm thinking of like a random slag of
course
i'm not thinking about the girl that
i've been seeing on and off for three
[ __ ] years of course you're thinking
about a random thing from down the way
yeah
and even even with that random girl that
dynamic is only gonna last for me for
like a month
two tops max it's not a three-year team
no
way no way no way
no what is that that's that's that gets
boring so far
it's like riding the roller coaster the
same roller coaster
every day for three years it's just like
okay this is boring now
it's like yeah this is like there's
other roller coasters that maybe not as
exciting
but they're more exciting than this
because i've done this i've
this is boring now let's try something
else so yeah to be fair it's not you but
yeah
it's not surprising that he's struggling
dude because yeah when you say it out
loud
sounds like a no-brainer
and she just started to cut you off he
was like and then i had to always give
him head to keep him hard
or he would just go down on me i'm
thinking were you not giving each other
ahead in the first place or
i don't know maybe maybe it's like a
maybe she means like mid
session maybe like yeah maybe they'll be
banging and then he'll be struggling so
she'll have to suck him up think him
hard again and then the bags are more
which is gross to be fair that's
horrible
he's got yeah that's how i know he feels
comfortable to even tell you that
like mid beat like oh you're gonna have
something if you want me to keep you
hard like if i want to stay hard they're
gonna have to something off
like i i wouldn't have the chance to say
that someone moved the journey on as
well
yeah does he take the johnny off and
then put another one back on it that
the best honest answer for you darling
is you need to evaluate
what you want from this guy yeah where
is this going where is this going
because if you clearly just see this
as a quickie as you put a drive by and
you know it's still going to continue
being on and off because you don't want
us
because you don't see anything further
with this spreader hence the reason why
you're using a condom because you've got
a kid
then you need to lock it today you get a
new one you can get you can get in you
can get a new drive by tomorrow
tomorrow because if it's just a drive-by
you want you don't really need to
have this emotional attachment with said
partner for three years
because it's clearly affecting you're
clearly upset that he isn't getting hard
anymore but if it's just a quickie then
you shouldn't really care about his
emotions and yeah you should just go get
a new one go get a new one
because he clearly sees you in a
different light yeah bro or you can
change the dynamic entirely
go in the direction that he wants to
which is not necessarily a relationship
or anything like that but just be like
just just speaking yeah speak to johnny
like big man in your wildest fantasies
what would you do to me
or would you want done to you bro and
then you can change this dynamic from a
drive by thing to some
crazy stuff yeah and just then it just
gets a bit more exciting for a bit
just i definitely think you should what
you said ask him what do you want to get
done to you
that's that's wildest fantasy ask him in
his wildest dreams
what do you want what do you want to do
to you what do you want me to do to you
and he might tell you some [ __ ]
and you might be like yuck and just lock
it off at least it's on the table
elisa's on the table
on the table and he's his juices are
flowing just from that question the
question
oh yeah man yeah but he'd lips you on
this
he lifts you on the spot after that
question yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah bro
yeah
um but yeah man good episode very good
absolutely this is a long one i'm not
sure if it is or not but i feel like it
is
um guys again thank you you sign up to
patreon like the video if you liked the
video comment
let's bump up this algorithm um guys if
you're about it
i'm bored of the same amount of likes
we've been getting i'm bored
bro let's go for like 600 likes 600.
that seems cool
600 likes on this one seems appropriate
um and then we're going to keep bumping
it up because
it's time to move now we're over 10k
subs now this is getting heinous
thank you by the way guys oh yeah thank
you thank you thank you guys 10k
that was dope club 10k we finally got
there for a while
there was a point where it was on nine
sutton for ages
oh yeah the nine to ten was a grind bro
but we got there it was decent man thank
you so much guys thank you to the
newbies thank you to the orbeez thank
you to the guys that just climb in and
out but
of course but um we're here man
all right guys thank you very much so
much guys